Good afternoon, everyone. My name is Huiping Liu.
I would like to welcome you on behalf of my co-chair, Dr.
John Taylor from MD Anderson. I'm from Northwestern
University. Our mini symposium is
to crack adaptive resistance using AI-enabled
screen-guided targeted approach in tumor
plasticity, DNA damage, metabolism, and
CTC-associated immunity.
So welcome to this mini symposium.
It's really a celebration for the trainees,
students, and faculty whose abstracts are
selected based on merit.
So I'd like to just disclose my scientific
conflict as a co-founder at Eximira Medicine.
A very brief introduction about AI.
I know AI is a big theme at this ACR meeting.
I don't know how many of you are using AI in your current
research. Can you raise your hand?
Okay, great. This is a great session for you.
We really want to see the specific applications in
our daily research. AI has been evolving over the
last 20-plus years, from machine learning to deep
learning foundation models, large language
models to most recently, agentic AI.
And this is in alignment with the NCI mission on
AI in cancer research. We hope to advance cancer
detection and treatment through AI innovation.
Just wanted to put this question ahead this session so you can
think of proactive questions we can have
as an open discussion during the oral talks
or at the final end discussion. We still have 10
minutes after seven talks. So how do we use
AI to really accelerate drug development and
overcome drug resistance? I believe our session is the only
session really specifically tailored to
research for drug development in this meeting.
And you can scan the barcode and submit your questions, or you can ask
questions later on. I just want to summarize, we have
seven chosen abstracts for the oral
presentation covering AI structural modeling
and translational research, as well as mitochondrial
metabolism, DNA damage
to tumor plasticity, and antitumor immunity
regulation.
I really wanted to congratulate the seven presenters
who can actually cover the cutting-edge research in these
topics.
Two of them, the first two, are related to
AI, DNA damage, and CTC cluster
formation, mechanisms, and targeting.
And the other three are mitochondria-related to metabolism
or translation regulation. And then two others
can be most directly related to niche plasticity and cancer
stemness. All seven related to drug development
or drug resistance mechanism studies.
And these are the landscape of the targets, including multiple cancer
models, as well as a lot of targets in
different signaling pathways.
Again, just to remind you, we hope this could be our
platform for proactive
discussions. How can we really celebrate our research
using the technology of AI? So the barcode is
here.
Let's go ahead to introduce our first speaker.
Our first speaker is Dr. Zaman Ahmed from MD
Anderson.
Thank you. And his talk is Chemical Trapping
of Inactive GRB2 Dimer Unveils a
Novel Cancer Vulnerability by Coupling Replication Stress to Antitumor
Immunity. Welcome.
Thank you very much. I'd like to thank the organizers for choosing the
abstract and giving me the opportunity to talk about this project.
This has been a long journey, so I'll take you through
it. And I'm happy to report that we have some very
good success, and these are my disclosures.
So I work with this adaptor protein GRB2.
It's discovered over 30 years ago for its role in Ras MAP
kinase signaling.
It's an adaptor, as I said. It has two SH3 domain and a SH2
domain. GRB2 was very early on, in early '90s, shown to be
embryonic lethal, very early stage.
However, in cancer cells, we can make knockout, and cells are perfectly
fine. However, they cannot tolerate any
exogenous DNA damage. So I categorized the
GRB2 signaling into three parts, the classic MAP kinase signaling and
cell motility and migration. And we recently
discovered a new role in DNA damage response, and I'm going to talk
about all of these pathway in the context of the inhibitors that we
have developed.
It's been a very attractive target for
drugs for over 30 years. But the problem was
that there is over 120 SH2 domain in human genome and
over 300 SH3, so specificity has always been the
issue for targeting GRB2. So we took a different
approach here. So when we look at the structure, we realize that there is
a very unique pocket in the dimer interface which can be targeted.
And on the right you can
seeThis pocket
is very attractive for a potential small molecule
inhibitor.
And our approach was to start with a very
well-curated library for an AI machine learning
algorithm. This is very important for anybody who's trying to start this
process, because it's often the libraries, what you
think they are, they're not. So if you do the measurement and then you train
AI on it, then you often get the wrong results.
So it's very important that you start with a set of compound,
and you do your biophysical measurement, and you know exactly what they are.
So that's exactly what we did.
We also put in some of the, what we call Goldilocks and
FDA-approved library. These tend to be promiscuous, but at
this point, we didn't care they're promiscuous.
We just want to teach the model how to
find binders versus non-binders, and to sort of have the
interaction. So once we build up this
learning process, what we could do then, very quickly have a
predicted
compound, and have a nanomolar affinity.
So that was very useful.
So,
I'm going to just now move on to one of the compound that we
then taken further and to look into more detail about
the signaling and how it works in cells.
So from the very early on, we wanted to look at how the compound
affects Ras MAP kinase. And I should say that GRAB2 dimer
is concentration dependent. So if you knock down GRAB2, as you can see,
EGF stimulated MAP kinase goes up because there is more monomers.
So monomers is the active form, dimers is the auto-inhibited
inactive form. And if you look at this NIH 333
cells, with the EGF receptors have been fully active, but the MAP
kinase is down with the inhibitor.
From our
compound series, we selected this compound,
G232, as one of the very
potent binder. And here I'm showing you a polarization assay
which measure the tumbling of molecules in solution.
So if it's a dimer, you see almost
twice the size. And that's exactly what we see,
the inhibitor is dimerizing the protein.
And we can also validate that using a mutation.
So there's a dimer interface mutation, asparagine to alanine,
and you can see the binding
is terminated.
And we tested
in cell culture to show that these
inhibitors actually go into cells, and they selectively kill
tumor cell over normal cell. Here, MRC5 when used as a normal
fibroblast.
So very early on, we wanted to see if this can have any therapeutic
potential. So we did a limited
mouse xenograft study where we
used a MDMB 231 cell xenograft and treated
these mice three times at 100 milligrams per kilograms
GRAB232. And we can see a tumor reduction.
So in order to understand the molecular mechanism, how
these inhibitors are working, when we looked at the MAP kinase, as you
remember earlier on I showed you, the knockout cells completely
inhibit MAP kinase, but these inhibitors weren't inhibiting
MAP kinase. When we look at the
active Ras, there is a reduction, but not enough
to suggest that this is the mechanism for
cytotoxicity. So we went and
looked at, in the live cells imaging, we fluorescently
tagged endogenous GRAB2. And when we added the
inhibitor, this is the profile we saw.
We saw a clustering of the protein into
this
intracellular vesicle. So as you would see, that cytoplasm clears
first, and then a nuclear GRAB2 comes out of the nucleus and sort of
sequestered in the cytoplasm. So
here again,
you can see the sequestering of the protein.
So we also published a couple of papers showing the GRAB2 involved in DNA
repair. So we wondered if the DNA repair pathways are
responsible for the cytotoxic effect.
Here on the left, untreated versus treated.
As you can see,
we see a clearing of the GRAB2 from the nucleus.
And this coincided with increased
gamma H2AX, which is a marker for DNA repair,
or a DNA damage marker. So we can also see that with the
western analysis. So then we
asked the question, what if we combine the inhibitor with the
radiation? So here we use ionizing radiation.
And as you can see on the bottom panel here, combining inhibitor with the
radiation, it completely traps most of the GRAB2
molecule into this DNA damage foci.
So in essence, these are the
dimer trapped. It's unable to monomerize, therefore,
we think it's not able to come out of that nuclear foci.
Also in our knockout studies, we show the GRAB2
knockout cells are sensitive to PARP
inhibitor. And we can
show the same in these synergy studies where the
GRAB2 inhibitor also synergizes cells
to PARP inhibitor.
In addition, in this paper, what we've seen, the GRAB2 knockout
cells treated with PARP inhibitor activate
cGAS-STING pathway, and we define the
mechanism as in replication stress.
And indeed, our inhibitor does the same.
So we think it's the inhibitor
working through the DNA repair pathway rather than MAP
kinase.Furthermore, what we
were able to show that the GRAB2 knockout cells treated with
Olaparib, they also secrete these pro-inflammatory cytokines.
And when we look at our inhibitor, we see the
same
outcome. So
one of the other function of GRAB2 is in cell motility.
And it's well established that GRAB2
work in this focal adhesion kinase integrin pathway,
where it promotes a cell motility.
And this is a paper a few years ago showing that knockdown of GRAB2 completely
inhibits cell migration in a
scratch assay. So we wondered if the inhibitor does the same, and
so here's the MDMB 231 cells, which you know
they're highly mobile. In treating
the cells with GRAB2 excuse me, GRAB2 inhibitor, we
see there's no cell movement into the wound at all.
And when we look at the
actin cytoskeleton, as you can appreciate,
these are polymerized actin, sort of
in a morphology where they're less dynamic
than those you see untreated cells.
So it's suggesting that there is a
connection between focal adhesion kinase integrin and the
actin cytoskeleton. So we further
to evaluate this, we looked at the focal adhesion kinase itself.
So the dynamicity of the focal adhesion kinase regulates
whether the actin
polymerization. As you can see from the image and the
quantification, what we find that in these cells, the focal
adhesion kinase is very stable,
longer. In essence, they're anchored very
well
here at the glass slide. So the whole dynamicity of the focal
adhesion kinase itself is inhibited by...
And we want to do more on this.
To summarize this, what I shown you is
we successfully
created a GRAB2 inhibitor
in a unique sort of way, using its
dimer interface to stabilize it. And based on our data
on the pro-inflammatory cytokine and so forth, we want to, in the future, want to
use a syngeneic model because when
we looked at the GRAB2 knockout cells treated with PARP inhibitor, we do see
those cells, those mice have much higher
benefit in terms of... And we see increased immune
signatures.
With that, I would like to thank all the people at John's lab.
MD Anderson, sort of their multiple institutional grant to sort
of make this possible, as well as CPRIT and NIH for funding. And thank you.
And last but not least, our chemist.
I mustn't forget him. So it's Darren Jones from University of Arkansas.
Thank you all for listening.
We're open for questions. Before you
come to the stand, and I'll ask the first one, Amo.
Given the large number of SH2,
SH3 domain proteins in human cells, how
do you ensure the selectivity or specificity of this
drug to GRAB2?
Well, that's exactly the point. So we didn't target the SH2
domain. We're really targeting the dimer interface.
I see.
And we
kind of rationalize that the dimer interface can only be formed when
two GRAB2 comes together.
Yeah.
So any other protein, that is unique to GRAB2.
So that's our rationale, and I think with the mutations,
we actually proved that. Yeah.
I see.
The second question-- Oh, go ahead, Alan.
Yeah, so this is very nice and confusing.
I'm trying to figure out how this connects with the DNA damage response.
So
the inhibitor
activates cGAS STING, so I'm thinking that does somehow the
inhibitor result in an increase in free
DNA or RNA in the cytoplasm? Because that ultimately
activates the cGAS STING pathway. Yeah.
Yeah.
Any thoughts there?
I have in it. So for the time, I didn't show it.
It's a knockout cells, when we treat with PARP inhibitor, we see
increased cytoplasmic DNA micronuclei,
and we see the same with the inhibitor.
So there's
inhibitor increases replication stress and fault
protection defects.
Right.
And that leads to increased cytoplasmic DNA and
activating cGAS and STING pathway.
Okay. So both the PARP inhibitor and the GRAB2 inhibitor
increase free DNA in the cytoplasm.
Combined, they're much more effective than on their own. Yeah.
Thank you.
Hi. David Schleper, UCSD. Interesting about
your
focal adhesion kinase connection.
Is it a direct binding interaction?
Because that is known, but it seems to be stabilizing
the adhesions. So do you know
what potential idea or hypothesis by
which this might be occurring?
So it's
still under... We don't know a lot about focal adhesion at this moment,
but what we're doing is we're stabilizing one
conformation over the other. So I think...
And in all our studies, what we see, the monomer is the active form,
and the dimer is the inactive form.
So the hypothesis is that a dimeric
GRAB2 interacting with focal adhesion kinase is sort
of-stabilizes the whole complex, and it doesn't move away.
Just like in the DNA, we see
in the nucleus, it gets trapped into this DNA damage foci.
And so in GRB2 biology, so a lot of the time it
acts very early. So it recruits a source and then
goes away within a few minutes. But if it remains
where it acts, I think that's when the cell starts to have problem.
But I think
there's a lot more for us to do to understand how,
in terms of the different system, how it's working.
One quick follow-up question. Do you see any changes in fact tyrosine
phosphorylation with this inhibitor?
So we see increased focal adhesion kinase
phosphorylation.
The Src
phosphorylation site-
Src
... 925. I can't remember off the top of my head, but one of the sites.
I have one more question. You briefly mentioned your machine learning
platform. Can you elaborate how a regular lab
can really do this kind of machine learning base, the screen
to get the drug at the very beginning?
So I think I kind of mentioned it. One thing that's really
important in AI, that you don't teach the wrong thing.
So it's a blank system. So often what we find, if you take
a library and then you have your best hit, and you
measure the binding,
or top 10. But if you were to mass spec those compound,
if they're not what they're supposed to be in the tube, then you're on the
completely wrong path. So any prediction-- So AI
thinks this is the structure, but in fact, in the tube, it's a
completely mixture of many different things.
So I think that's
fundamentally the most important thing for AI machine
learning, is that you have to start with a very well-curated
compound library that you know exactly what they are, and you have
proof that if you see a hit,
it is the structure that the AI is docking.
Because otherwise, you get into this problem that will
take years to figure out.
Thank you. Thank you so much, Emil. Let's give another round of applause.
So I'm
very pleased to introduce our speaker from
Northwestern, Dr.
Fangjia Tong, and you should correct your name if I
mispronounced it. This will be an exciting talk
on AI applied to
circulating tumor cell clusters and the
discovery of pleksin B as a driver.
Hello, everyone. I'm Fangjia Tong from Northwestern
University. And today I'm excited to share our study on
AI-guided discovery and the targeting of pleksin B2
in the circulating tumor cell cluster-driven metastasis.
Of course, we know that circulating tumor cells disseminate from the
primary tumor into the bloodstream, where they may exist as
single CTCs, homotypic clusters composed
only of tumor cells, or heterotypic cluster that include
both tumor cells and white blood cells.
Importantly, CTC clusters exhibit up to a
50-fold higher metastatic potential compared to
single CTCs. Recent study from our lab has
shown that the homotypic CTC clusters are
negatively associated with patient survival.
In addition, the heterotypic CTC clusters are also
associated with poor clinical outcomes, highlighting the
important role of CTC clusters in driving metastasis.
So this lead us to ask, what are the key regulators that
drive CTC cluster formation?
To answer this question, we recently developed a novel
computational-guided ranking score, called R-score, to
systemically prioritize cell adhesion molecules that are
involved in CTC cluster formation and
breast cancer metastasis.
Using this approach, we integrated proteomic data
across multiple data sets, including human breast tumor,
normal tissues, triple-negative breast cancer cell line, and the
patient-derived CTCs. By integrating this data,
we identified 30 overlapping adhesion proteins.
Among them, we prioritized a transmembrane protein
called pleksin B2 as the top
candidate. Next, we want to functionally
validate pleksin B2. To do so, we generated a
stable knockout 4T1 mouse breast cancer cells and
implanted either control or knockout cells into the
immune competent balb c mice using a spontaneous
metastasis model. After nine days, we harvest the
lungs and quantify the micro metastases using
H&E analysis.
As shown here, compared to the control group, we observe
that loss of pleksin B2 lead to a significant
reduction in the lung metastasis.
In addition, we also analyzed the CTCs in the blood
using flow cytometry.
We observed a significant reduction in single CTCs
and heterotypic CTC white blood cell clusters,
particularly CTC myeloid cell clusters in the knockout
group.
To determine whether this finding extend to patient, we
also analyzed the CTCs in the patient blood sample using
CellSearch, which is a FDA-approved platform
for CTC detection and
enumeration.Consistent with our experimental
data, plexin B2 was found significantly
enriched in both homotypic and heterotypic CTC
clusters compared to single CTCs.
In addition, in human triple-negative breast cancer, high
plexin B2 expression is also associated with
worse distant metastasis-free survival, supporting its
clinical relevance in metastasis.
So given the critical role of plexin B2, we next sought
to develop neutralizing antibodies to target it.
To do so, we leveraged the antibody language model developed in
our lab. This model was trained on large-scale
antibody sequences, including SARS-CoV-2
antibodies generated during COVID-19 pandemic.
It learns generalizable antibody features that govern
the antibody affinity and activity.
So as a result, it can be broadly applied and
rapidly screen and prioritize candidate antibodies
in silico against new antigens such as
plexin B2, reducing the reliance on
experimental trial and error.
Importantly, our antibody language model
outperforms existing protein language model with a
75% true positive rate in predicting
antibody performance,
highlighting its strong power for antibody prediction.
Building on this, we next integrated this antibody
language model into our iterative
antibody discovery pipeline.
First, the antibody language model identified
antibodies with high functional potential.
Then these candidates were experimentally validated for
binding affinity and activity, followed by iterative
redesign to further optimize their performance.
Using this framework, we extended to the plexin B2
antibody discovery.
To further refine our pipelines, we incorporated
AI-driven structure modeling to the antibody prediction.
First, we used AlphaFold 3, which is an AI
model, to predict antibody-antigen
structure and evaluate the confidence between their
interaction.
We then converted a total of 106
anti-plexin B2 monoclonal antibody sequences into
3D structures using AbBuilder 3. In
parallel, we also analyzed the plexin B2 structure
and identified potential binding epitope using
ProABC2.
Finally, we performed the molecular docking and the binding
energy calculation to model the antibody-antigen
interaction and quantitatively prioritize top candidates.
During the molecular docking step, Dock generates over
500 models per antibody. From this, we selected the
top 10 models for each antibody and
evaluate them using a multi-metric framework,
including Dock score, reflecting overall interaction
quality, DockQ score measuring the docking accuracy,
free energy indicating the interaction strength, and
predicted affinity estimating the binding tightness.
By integrating these metrics,
we established a normalized scoring framework to
prioritize top candidates.
Importantly, AI-guided candidates showed strong
concordance with fax binding assays.
Among this experiment, we can see lots of candidates
showed strong binding activities, so they were further
advanced for the functional validation.
To validate them, we first performed the in vitro clustering
assay. Specifically, we used human triple-negative breast
cancer MDA-MB-231 cells to model the homotypic
cluster or co-culture with THP-1 monocytes to
model the heterotypic cluster. After the antibody treatment,
the cells were incubated at 37 degree to
allow the cluster formation, and we will confirm
another cluster analysis.
As shown here, the candidate antibody effectively block
the cluster formation, reducing both homotypic
tumor-tumor clusters and heterotypic tumor
monocyte cluster, with a significant reduction in
both cluster size and cluster counts.
Next, we move to the in vivo testing.
First, we evaluate the antibody efficacies using
immune deficient NSG mice. Due to the time limit, I will
skip the experimental details, but in this setting, the
anti-plexin B2 antibody treatment lead to a
significant reduction in lung metastasis.
Importantly, although these antibodies were originally
developed to against the human plexin B2, but they also
showed cross-reactivity with mouse plexin B2.
This allows us to further evaluate their therapeutic
efficacies in the immune competent mouse
model.
Using a similar experimental design, we further tested
this antibody in BALB/c mice.
In this setting,
even a single dose of anti-plexin B2 treatment lead to
significant reduction in metastatic burden, as
confirmed by both in vivo imaging and ex vivo
lung H&E analysis.So in conclusion,
we identified plexin B2 as a key driver for the
CTC cluster-driven breast cancer metastasis, and we
also established the AI-guided structure modeling
pipeline to help prioritize the candidate antibodies.
In the future, we want to further test this antibody using a
spontaneous metastasis model and assess their toxicity.
And we also want to establish an AI experimental feedback
loop to further refine the antibody prediction.
Finally, I'd like to thank my lab members and my PI,
Dr. Liu, for their support, and the collaborator, Dr.
Hu, who developed anti-plexin V2 antibody, and then
Martina, the rotation student who contributed to the
computational aspect of this study.
Thank you, and I'm happy to take any questions.
So
while people are making their way to the microphone for questions,
I wanted to
jump in and ask you if you can maybe comment
on how AI-guided antibody
discovery may be further leveraged to really accelerate
sort of clinically actionable targets and
therapeutic antibodies.
Thank you for your question. It's a good question.
From our study in the AI, first, it helped to
shorten the timeline for the antibody screening.
As shown here, we have over 100 monoclonal antibodies to
target plexin B2. If we only rely on the
classical experimental trial and error, which is
time-consuming and maybe take years to finish, and
with AI's help, it can help us to shorten the timeline.
This is the first point. And second,
AI is not only to shorten the time point, but also give
us a feedback and help us to
further modify the antibodies, gives us some guidance.
This will be the second thing I want to emphasize.
Yeah, with this help, I think
we can finish this
with a shortened time. Thank you.
Yeah, thank you. Alan?
Yeah, it's a very nice talk. I really don't know very much about plexin B2,
but where is it made and where does it come from?
And can you reduce it at
its source? Where does it come from?
It's a great question. Plexin B2 is not only expressed
on tumor cells. Even in our study, we identified it's
highly enriched in CTC tumor cells.
But in some normal immune cells, for example,
the monocytes in the blood and also neuron cells in
the brain, it also expressed. But the good thing is,
even it expressed in some normal cells, but
the antibody, its penetration to
the cross BBB, blood-brain barrier, is
limited, so it can help to reduce the potential
toxicity. Yeah. Thank you for your question.
Great talk. Thank you. I'm Christina from the University of Rochester.
So you mentioned three different types of clusters at the beginning.
So you also introduced two clusters, the h**o and
hetero. I'm wondering if you have done anything with the cluster with
WBC.
Yeah. In
my first slide, I introduced our recent study, which is
published in last year in JCI. And in that study,
we performed a
comprehensive immune profiling of heterotypic
clusters. And from there, we identified the major two
clusters,
including the tumor and tumor cells with T
cells and followed by with neutrophil, and that is
over 30% in overall. And for the
CTC myeloid cell clusters, we only identified with
monocytes. And we also identified different immune cells, for
example, NK cells and B cells within the heterotypic clusters.
But for their functional, we have no idea.
That will be the future direction for us to
investigate. Thank you.
Okay. Thank you.
Great talk. A quick question. Have you looked at multiple antibodies
that were predicted by your AI model?
Like are the ones that are predicted to not be so good,
less good than the one that's predicted to be
good?
Yeah. In our AI models, we only have 80%
concordance. It's good, but it's not
perfect. So we want to use our experimental data to
further train our model and to refine its prediction power.
Thank you.
But you only tested the one that's supposed to be the best.
Yeah.
So how do you know that one that is supposed to be the worst
doesn't work just as well?
Yeah. This is preliminary data, so we will further test this
antibody in the future. Thank you.
Thank you, Fangja. And we'll move on to our
third speaker.
Our third talk is by Henry Chen
from Johns Hopkins University. The talk is
SWALL-1 controls epigenetic methylation,
mitochondrial metabolism, and antitumor immunity in
IDH mutant gliomas.
Thank you.
Before I start, I would like to thank the organizer for the opportunity to present
our work. I would also like to thank Dr. Liu and Dr.
Tanner for moderating this session.
So
I'm Henry. I'm a sixth-year PhD student in Johns Hopkins, and
I'll be happy to take any questions. Move forward.
So-I have no disclosure.
So
to start the story, I would like to introduce the IDH mutations.
That is the most common metabolic alterations occurs in human cancers, as
illustrated up here with the illustration here.
So IDH mutations occurs in
two forms,
on either the IDH1 enzymes or IDH2 enzymes.
So among these cancers, glioma appears to be one of the unique
ones, is that,
first, the majority of the glioma, especially
low-grade glioma patients, harbors this IDH mutation.
Moreover,
the majority of the IDH mutation occurs in the IDH1 or
132H forms. So the mutation of these enzymes
is a gain-of-function mutations.
So while the wild type of IDH mutation-- wild type enzymes that
converts between the alpha-ketoglutarate and the isocitrate convergence,
the IDH mutations
gives it a neomorphic functions to further convert this
catalyzation from alpha-ketoglutarate to the D-2
hydroxyglutarate, or the D-2HG, so-called the oncometabolite.
So upon the discovery of these mutations, people have spent
extensive effort to understand the biology of IDH
mutations or D-2HG inside and outside the cells.
About 10 years ago, people started to
characterize the tumors microenvironments of these IDH
mutant cancers. And they found that these IDH mutant cancers harbors the
specific very immune cold environment.
In the last few years, the studies from Dr.
Masha Haigis from Harvard and Dr. Michael Platten in Germany,
specifically identified that the uptake of the D-2HG into the
tumor-infiltrating T cells or macrophages suppresses their
antitumor immunity through the antigen presentation
functions or the cytotoxic activation of the T cells.
However, there still is still one gap between our understanding about how D-2HG
mediates this tumor microenvironment that is... Sorry.
That is the molecular pathway that mediating the release of this
oncometabolite is remains unknown, as the oncometabolite
exists as a negative charge form that precludes its
passive diffusion across the plasma membranes.
So to study the membrane transport of these metabolites,
we use this human U87 glioblastoma cell line that harbors
the IDH1 mutations with the knocking system to
investigate its
membrane transport mechanisms. So to first characterize
the existence of the D-2HG, we collaborate
with Dr. Lisa Crace in the Kennedy Krieger Institute and to quantify the D-2HG
levels inside and outside the cell.
As you can see that the cells harboring this knocking mutation produce
abundant levels of the D-2HG. More surprisingly, we know this study,
about 25-fold increase of the release of this
2HG from outside the cells comparing to that is within the
cells.
We also notice that this D-2HG release is a time-dependent
manner, showing here on the linear manner.
And then it does not accompany with the observable
LDH activity table on the corresponding supernatants,
suggesting that these metabolites released by the living
cells.
So the membrane transport of these small molecules can be
roughly separated by the active or passive mechanisms.
So the active mechanism includes the extracellular vesicles and/or the
ATP-dependent manners.
To roughly test whether D-2HG is mediated by the active mechanisms,
we use the 10 kDA filtering to exclude the extracellular vesicles
or use the ATP depletion to remove the ATP-dependent pump
activities inside these cells. To our surprise that neither of these
approach
change the secretion level of the D-2HG, indicating that the D-2HG
is released through a passive mechanism.
So the passive mechanism includes the SLC transporters or the
ion channel manners.
To specifically understand what is the potential transporter or the channels
that mediating the D-2HG release, we do a simple
siRNA screening, targeting the previous
implicated SLC transporters or ion channels that
potentially can mediate the
2HG release through the passive manner.
Specifically, the SLC22 family has been suggested that it mediates
the release of a 2HG in the overexpression manner, or the SLC1 or
SLC13 has been implicated in the uptake of the 2HG.
To our surprise, we noticed that a
knockdown of the SWELL1, which is a essential subunit for the volume-regulating
anion channel,
dramatically decreased the release of D-2HG from two supernatant.
So what is this ion channels? The volume-regulating anion
channel, or the VRAC, is a
heterohexameric
of ion channel that is composed by this SWELL1
with one or more other subunits from the LRRC8A
families that comprise of BCDE subunits.
So to form a functional channel, it has to be a A together with a
BCD
subunits, mixed up subunits. And then
after a discovery of this identity of this channel, it has been
implicated to be the membrane transport of many different
metabolites or single molecules such as the cGMP, ATP, or the
glutamate. To further understand what's the composition of VRAC
channel that mediates this release, we perform the further siRNA knockdown
of each one of these subunits. And then interestingly, we found
that the LRRC8Cknockdown decreased around
25% of the IIAG release, indicating that A and C
combination could be the ion channel that is responsible for this release.
Interestingly, we also noticed that there's a 25% increase upon the
AD knockdown, indicating that when an AD subunit
goes down, there's more AC-containing channels on that is being
assembly onto the plasma membrane that facilitate that IIAG release.
So to test this function more broadly,
we
performed a CRISPR-mediated knockout of the SOX1 across
different cell lines that harbors endogenous or transduced IDH mutation.
That includes the U87 used for initial characterization, the
endogenous patient-derived cells, the glioma cells
of the TS603, two of the transduced models.
One is the human model, and the other one is mouse primary
glioma cells, as well as the commonly used NG30 and the HeLa cells.
This suggests that the knockout of the SOX1 decreased the IIAG
release from about 40% to 60%, indicating that VRAC may
serve as a major pathway for the release of the IIAG molecule.
To test whether this VRAC-dependent IIAG release is functional relevant in
the disease setting or the glioma setting, we work with Dr.
Maria Castro in the University of Michigan, to use this,
mouse de novo high-grade glioma cells.
The glioma cells derived from these high-grade glioma models that harbors the
transduced IDH1 mutation or its isogenic control.
So as most of people do here in the field, that we orthotopically
xenograft these cells to the mouse, and upon
euthanasia criteria meet, we collect the
tumor, mechanically digest it, and use the CD45 beads to enrich the cells and
run the facts analysis.
We first analysis the myeloid cell populations and notice that
there's increased antigen-presenting activity indicated by the
CD86 and IIE expression levels on the microglia and the
macrophages within the SOX1 knockout tumors.
This is also accompanied by the increased CD8 cells activation, as
indicated by the increase in the interferon gamma, granzyme B, surface
CD107 expression, as well as decreased PD-1 expression.
And more importantly,
when we harvest the tumor adjacent tissues from these mouse, where we
quantify the D2-AG levels in these brain tissues, we notice there's a
significant decrease of the D2-AG amount
around these tumors, indicating the role of the SOX1 or
VRAC-mediated D2-AG release.
When we track the tumor progression, we notice that the decrease of the
tumor progression and the survival benefit for the
mouse harboring SOX1 knockout tumors.
Although it's worth noting that this can be contributed by the increased
immunoactivation or the tumor intrinsic decreased proliferation.
So we first analyze the tumor proliferation, the tumor cell proliferation
activity indicating by the Ki67 staining or the CON information.
Aligning with the past literatures, we notice that
the IDH mutant cells grows slower than the wild type controls,
while the SOX1 knockout further decrease their
growth activity. And this does not occur in these isogenic wild type controls,
indicating that this has to be in the IDH mutant
context. So we wonder whether this can be coming from the loss of a
release which might induce the accumulation of the IIAG inside the cell
palate, then this is what we see. We notice around twofold increase of
IIAG accumulation inside these cells.
And
inside the cells, the IIAG has been established to be a epigenetic
modulator that induce hypermethylation of the DNA and histone through the
inhibition of the demethylases that require the alpha-Kg
to act as a co-substrate. And because the structural similarity between these two
molecules, D2AG actually inhibits these demethylase functions.
So that's what we see when we isolated the histone from these cells.
We notice that IDH mutant cells indeed have increased, histone
trimethylations, and these trimethylations
are being enhanced in our SOX1 knockout cells.
And
similarly, this occurs in the wild type setting, as we don't see it in
the wild type cells. And then this is accompanied by the DNA
methylations.
And to cut a long story short, we run the ATAC-seq and RNA-seq,
integrate these analysis to understand the functional outcome of
these hypermethylations, given that
some of these marks are transcriptionally active and some of these are
transcriptionally repressive. So what we found is that the proliferation programs
are being downregulated co-simultaneous at the genome and
transcript levels. Out of these analysis, we notice the MYC and SOX2 are the two
major transcription factors that have been downregulating in these settings,
together with some of other onco genes.
And due to time restraint, I'll just move on
with
the following result. So another important
aspect of these IDH mutant gliomas is the metabolic
alterations, given that IDH itself is a metabolic enzyme.
So work with Dr. Chris Ju in the Ohio State University, we noticed
that the TCA cycle intermediate is downregulating upon the SOX1
deletion, and this is accompanied by the seahorse mitochondrial respiration
decrease. And with the
defect in these respiration or metabolic activity, cells tend to use a
secondary metabolic pathway to support their growth and energy production.
And this can be implicated by the glutaminolysis.
As you can see that the glutamine and glutamate levels are
decreased within these cells. And this creates a unique vulnerability
of targeting metabolic pathways
toward the IDH mutant gliomas.
As you can see that the metabolic inhibition to these cells, or
IDH wild type cells are actually less sensitive or insensitive toward these
inhibitions, while the IDH mutant cells shows a significantly cell
death upon the inhibition. And this is
amplified in our SOX1 knockout cells.
And then this is the last part of the result. I'm sorry for the delay.
So basically, because most of the results aredone in the mouse
cells. So we've basically verified our cells using a human patient-derived
IDH mutant context. We generated SWI/SNF knockout cells.
We observed the same accumulation, histone
hypermethylation, decrease of the MEK and SOX2, and the sensitivity toward
the inhibitions. And then when we grow these cells
in the skin mice brain, we do notice that the tumor progression is slower, and then
it provides the survival benefit to these skin mice.
So in summary, I hope that I have convinced you that the
SOX1 channel or the VirA channel mediates the uncle Matt hybrid transport that is
important for the tumor cell fitness, as
well as the immunosuppression in the tumor microenvironment.
And that, I will conclude my
story. And then I would like to thank Dr.
Zhao-Fu Chu, my mentor in Johns Hopkins, and then all the
collaborators and people I met in Hopkins. Thank you.
Thank you, Henry.
We'll give the audience a chance to ask one question.
I'll start with
one question. You talk about the specific
R132H mutation of IDH. Are there
any other specific mutations would make these tumor cells
sensitive to the depletion of the
complex or the ion channel?
You-
Yeah, you mean-
Other oncodrives or?
On the IDH mutations, are there specific mutations or any
mutations of IDH will actually sensitize to the
depletion or the inhibition of this channel?
I think for most of our study, we mostly focusing on IDH mutant
context. And when we do the control experiment in the wild-type setting, we
didn't notice much of the change in the SWI knockout context.
Yeah. But even for the IDH mutations-
Mm-hmm
... have you tested others in addition to the R132H you used?
Oh. Oh, that's a good point. I think we haven't tested that because in the glioma
setting, it's mostly the IDH1 mutations, but I do feel like it would be the
case if we have other forms of the IDH1 mutations or even the
IDH2. Although we do feel like one thing to note is that
IDH2 mutations occurs in the mitochondria, so the most of
the 2HG will be trapped within the mitochondria.
So I would expect the phenotype will be maybe smaller with
the IDH2 mutation.
Maria, you're asked.
Sure. Go ahead. There is question from the back.
Hi. Do you see that the SWI
channel is more highly expressed in IDH mutant tumors?
And do you see a change when you inhibit IDH?
Yes. So one
gene expression is ubiquitous, so basically it's expressing almost all
tissues. And then we do notice that if we compare, this is from the TCGA
database, if we compare the SWI expression levels in wild type and mutant
IDH tumors, IDH mutant tumors have around one point fold
increase in SWI expression.
All right. Thank you, Henry.
Thank you.
Mm-hmm.
So I want to introduce our next talk from
Memorial Sloan Kettering. It will be
by Xiao Chenluo Lu,
and on lineage plasticity, investigating how
transcriptional reprogramming leads to antibody
drug conjugate resistance in bladder cancer. So thank you.
Sure.
You can-
... correct your name if you want.
No, you're correct. Thank you for the very kind introduction,
and good afternoon, everyone. It's my great honor and pleasure today to
present our team's work on understanding the
regulatory drivers of lineage plasticity and antibody
drug conjugate therapy resistance in urothelial bladder cancer.
So bladder cancer is the number ninth most common cancer type around the world,
and the majority of bladder cancer is urothelial carcinoma, which
arises from the transitional epithelium of the urinary tract.
And depends on whether the tumor cells invade into
the deeper muscle layer. This can be further classified as non-muscle
invasive and muscle invasive bladder cancer, which is
apparently a more aggressive disease with worse prognosis and
limited effective treatment options.
However, the treatment landscape of bladder cancer has been largely
transformed by antibody drug conjugates recently,
especially enfortumab vedotin, a nectarine four targeting
ADC that has shown remarkable efficacy in multiple
clinical trials. And now EV plus the immunotherapy
pembrolizumab has become a new standard of care for
bladder patient with an advanced disease.
And lineage plasticity is one of the cancer hallmarks describing the
cell's ability to change between different cell states.
And in bladder cancer, this can further manifest as the morphologic
heterogeneity that the pathologists usually use the
term variant histology to describe it.
So, in addition to the most common urothelial carcinoma,
which we will call UCNOS for short, there are around
20 to 30% of bladder tumors can, out of
varying histologies, showing, for example, squamous,
glandular, or small cell neuroendocrine cell-like morphology.
In these histologic classifications is clinically important
as they correlate with distinct prognosis.
And as shown here, the UCNOS group is of a
relatively better prognosis, while subtypes such
as sarcomatoid, squamous, and plasmacytoid
are usually associated with a worse clinical outcome.
So in order to understand the underlying
biology of this phenotypic plasticity, our team has
assembled an in-house variant histology clinical
cohort at Memorial Sloan Kettering, where we collect over
300 bladder tumors of the histology of
UCNOS or variant histologies. And we then perform
multi-omics profiling on these tumor samples, including
DNA, RNA sequencing, and for some interesting selective
cases, we did special transcriptomic analysis.
So, the bulk RNA seq data actually identified a
profound transcription of heterogeneity across these
histologic variants.
AndEspecially in the expression of lineage
markers and ADC targets. So overall, we think
these histologic variants can be classified into two groups.
One is urothelial-like, such as plasmacytoid and
micropapillary. These subtypes still retained a
luminal signature and expressed high level of the luminal transcription
factors GATA3, PPA gamma, and FOXA1.
And at the same time, they also maintained a high expression of these ADC
targets, including Nectin-4. However, there
are some subtypes that have been through lineage transition
that they lost their luminal genes and start to
express alternative lineage markers such as basal
squamous, neuroendocrine, and sarcomatoid.
And these subtypes tend to have a reduced or
absent expression of Nectin. So, in order to understand
what caused this lineage change and the differential
Nectin expression, we performed the master regulator
analysis, or you can call it regulome analysis based on the
bulk RNA seq data. And quite similar as small cell
lung and prostate cancer, we identified
ASCL1 and NEUROD1 as neuroendocrine
subtype-specific transcription factors.
And to further validate their functions, we
overexpressed them in a luminal bladder cancer cell line,
HT1376, which harbors TP53
and RB1 mutation, the two most commonly mutated
genes seen in bladder cancer patients with neuroendocrine tumors.
And the overexpression of ASCL1 and NEUROD1
can lead to significant downregulation of Nectin.
So, this supports the hypothesis that lineage
plasticity, which is driven by the activation of
subtype-specific drivers, is
a mechanism of the ADC target loss.
And we further want to understand this correlation spatially,
so here is an example of a bladder tumor with mixed
histology of mostly squamous and neuroendocrine
subtype. And the spatial transcriptomics further validate that
the basal squamous signature was restricted only in the squamous
region,
and the neuroendocrine-associated genes as well as
ASCL1 regulome activity were enriched
in the neuroendocrine area. And consistent with our bulk RNA
seq data, we see expression of ADC targets, including
Nectin-4 and Trop-2, was markedly reduced in these
neuroendocrine components. And this
heterogeneous Nectin expression directly mediates the
variable response to enfortumab vedotin in patients.
So here in another smaller clinical cohort, we assessed the
time that
a bladder cancer patient stay on the enfortumab vedotin treatment.
And on the left, there is a swimmer plot showing that patients who have
high Nectin-4 expressing tumors tend to have a better response to
this drug and tend to stay longer on EV treatment.
However, patients who have the variant histology tumor,
especially the subtypes that have very low Nectin-4 expression,
such as neuroendocrine and sarcomatoid, this patient does
not respond
well to EV and tends to stay a shorter
duration of time on this drug. So, we
then wonder how can we address this limited
EV sensitivity in those patients with varying histology
tumors. So one of the potential strategy is to identify
alternative drug targets for these subtypes.
So we assessed a long list of the drug targets that's
either being well-established or under active
investigation. And we identified that for the subtypes that
lost Nectin expression, they oftentimes gain the expression of some
other drug targets that can be potentially used.
For example, the neuroendocrine tumors
has very low Nectin expression, but they have a significant
upregulation of DL3 specifically.
And this can be further validated with the IHC
staining in a mixed histology tumor,
showing that in the neuroendocrine components, we have very low Nectin
staining, but DL3's level is elevated
significantly.
So this kind of
suggesting that there is a possibility that we can target
these heterogeneous tumors
using combinations of ADCs. So, to sum
up, I've shown that there is a profound transcriptional
heterogeneity across these bladder cancer histologic
variants, and they can be broadly classified into two groups.
One is still urothelial-like, and the other includes the ones
that have features of lineage plasticity.
And we've also shown that lineage plasticity, which is driven by the
activation of the lineage-specific drivers,
can be a mechanism of ADC target loss and
corresponding therapy resistance.
And last but most importantly, we've shown the potential
of using combination of ADCs to target these
phenotypic heterogeneous bladder tumors with mixed
histology. So with that, I would like to thank
our patients and their families, and also our amazing scientists and
physicians in the Solit Lab, especially my mentor, Dr.
Solit, and I'm happy to take questions from here.
Thank you.
So we have time for discussion. Maybe I'll start by
justNoting it's always a challenge
in cancer biology to have predictive knowledge.
So I wondered if you could comment on molecular
signatures or biomarkers that might be
predictive for
the activity of the ADC
sensitivity.
Yeah. That's a very great question.
I guess that's also something the field has been working on in the past years.
So,
if you think about the structure of this ADC, it has antibody
components, linker components, and the payload.
So each one of them is individual factors, and I have shown
in my talk that nectin-4 expression itself is very important for the
response to EV. And actually, not only the
nectin
overall expression matters, like where this is expressed it's also
an essential factor. So there's actually a
work from our institute presented in GeoOSCO showing
that if nectin-4 expressing on the membrane, membrane's
nectin expression is a positive biomarker for EV
response, that instead,
if it's expressing the
cytoplasm, it's an active biomarker for it.
And also, I guess there's a work from UC San Francisco
showing that molecular subtypes of bladder cancer also matters a lot.
Like luminal tumors tend to respond better than basal ones, and
the neuroendocrine subtype tends to have the lowest nectin-4
level and going to be resistant to EV treatment in general.
Yeah. Thank you. Alan, did you want to start,
or we take it from the back first. You choose.
Yeah.
Alan can go.
Alan, you're up.
Oh, I'm up?
Okay. I know very little about this.
I'm learning more
from my son, who's in the David Solit lab Vincent
D'Andrea.
So does
EV therapy result in a loss of
nectin-4, and is that an
acquired resistance to EV therapy?
And,
yeah. So if you lose nectin-4, it sounds like your
ADC is not working anymore, and that's why you
need new ADCs. Is that
correct?
That's a very interesting point. I guess
since the drug just started to be given to patients, and we are still
collecting a lot of treated samples.
But, I think,
to my knowledge, there's a work still from UC San Francisco
showing that, in a kind of smaller cohort, if
you compare pre-EV treatment and EV-treated patients,
if you do IHC staining, you actually not necessarily see
loss of nectin. Well, I guess this conclusion might be different
if you have a larger number of the patient samples.
But I guess that kind of answer your point, answer your questions.
And
can you remind me of the second point?
No. Just I was wondering, I'm always interested-
Yeah
... in acquired resistance to a treatment, and obviously the
EV therapy is a big deal for bladder
cancer,
but it's going to fail.
And when it fails, you're going to get new ADC
targets expressed.
I think. That's what I'm learning from your talk here.
Is that the direction of the therapy now?
Yeah. I've shown you one of the possibility that we might be able to
use combinations of ADCs that again,
it's acquired resistance, so
it's a
lineage plastic process, so the cell is now fixed in
one cell state. There is also a chance that you can try to reverse
this plasticity to make them start to express
nectin-4 somehow. So there's other opening opportunities
that we can potentially think about.
Thank you.
Thanks.
Hi. My question is slightly in the same vibe.
Are those specimen that you've collected post-treatment?
Those are pre-treatment. Yeah.
Those are pre-treatment. Okay. Then my follow-up questions, I'm a bit surprised
that you have patients with neuroendocrine that were treated with EV pembro,
because first line will be more of a platinum plus etoposide treatment.
It's-
Yeah, but those are very small number.
We can go next.
Okay.
So, and that will be then a minor component of those
tissue. We were having, I guess, major of
UC plus having some neuroendocrine component of it.
Sorry, can you repeat the question?
Well, that's okay. I was just wondering why they were treated that way.
And the second question I guess I will go with is, do you have any access
to post-treatment tissue to assess if you have selections, like
a loss of nectin or something like that? That'll be of interest.
Sorry, I'm going to answer your first question first.
So
these samples are pre-EV treatment, and...
Sorry, I didn't quite get your second question.
Can you repeat or rephrase it?
It's okay. It was just a suggestion.
My first comment was I was slightly surprised that you have
neuroendocrine bladder cancer treated with enfortumab vedotin,
as this is an entity that medical oncologists will be treating mostly with
platinum and etoposide line of treatment of a small cell type of
drug chemo regimen. So that was my first surprise of how you
had those tissue.
Mm-hmm.
And I was assuming that those were post-treatment biopsy.
So it just lead to my second suggestion simply of mentioning if you do
get access to those post-treatment tissue, that probably will be interested
for you guys to look at.
Okay, thank you.
I guess we can have a discussion how to really
predict maybe using AI in the future to make
this more predictable, and then we can be one step ahead
of the tumor cell plasticity. Yeah. Thank you.
Thanks.
Let's move on to our next talk.
It's from Dr.
Xiaoxu Zhang, Beckman Research Institute of the
City of Hope. The topic is--
Oh, it's actually a student.
So congratulations. The topic is on
eIF4A1 inhibition to targeted
translation of factors.
Welcome.
Good afternoon. Thanks for the committee for selecting our work for the
oral presentation. Today, I will share an
unpublished story focusing on eIF4A1 in
AML.
Acute myeloid leukemia is an aggressive blood malignancy
with very poor five-year survival rate.
It has signatures of myeloid differentiation block, metabolic
reprogramming, and uncontrolled expansion of leukemia
stem cells.
Compared with the normal hematopoietic cells, AML cells
requires high levels of protein synthesis and rapid messenger
RNA translation efficacy.
Messenger RNA translation consists of three steps, translation
initiation, elongation, and termination.
Amongst three steps, translation initiation is the rate-limiting
step, which is achieved by various translation
initiation factors.
Here we comprehensively analyzed the expression of all the
currently known translation initiation factors across
different AML cell lines, and found that eIF4A1
is the most highly expressed translation initiation factor.
Moreover, compared with the normal hematopoietic cells,
eIF4A1 is significantly upregulated in AML
cells.
To assess the role of eIF4A1 in leukemogenesis, we
next employed the immunocompetent bone marrow transplantation
assay.
The result demonstrated that the knockdown of eIF4A1
substantially prolonged the mice survival.
And in another human-in-mouse engrafted mouse model, the
knockout of eIF4A1 significantly reduced the AML
burden and also prolonged the mice survival.
Therefore, eIF4A1 promotes leukemogenesis.
To better understand how eIF4A1 exerts its function in
AML, we next performed integrated multi-omics
analysis of RNA-seq and proteomics.
Here, as we can see, the knockout eIF4A1 significantly
decreased a large number of genes expression at both RNA
level and protein level. Interestingly, upon eIF4A1
knockout, a greater number of genes were decreased at the RNA
level compared with the protein level.
That indicates that eIF4A1 contributes to the
post-transcriptional regulation in addition to its
traditional role in the translational regulation.
Therefore, we focus on the 500 genes which
were significantly downregulated upon eIF4A1
knockout at both RNA level and protein level,
particularly on the genes who showed a more robust
decrease at the RNA level than at the protein level.
GSEA pathway analysis showed a strong enrichment of the
metabolism-related pathways, where
serine biosynthetic process pathway is the most
significant one.
And among the core enriched genes within this pathway,
PHGDH, SHMT2, PSPH, and
PSAT1 stood out.
Metabolic profiling independently verified the
impact of eIF4A1 on AML metabolism.
Over 250 metabolites were decreased following
eIF4A1 knockout, and the pathway analysis of the
decreased metabolites showed a strong enrichment of the
amino acid-related pathways, including glycine,
serine metabolism pathway, where PHGDH
serves as a rate-limiting enzyme.
The knockout of eIF4A1 leads to a dramatic decrease
of PHGDH messenger RNA and protein levels, and the
overexpression of PHGDH substantially reversed
eIF4A1 knockout-induced AML cell growth
inhibition and oxophos reduction.
Therefore, eIF4A1 promotes serine biosynthesis via
PHGDH.
Typically, eIF4A1 interacts with eIF4E and
eIF4G to form eIF4F complex and
promote cap-dependent translation.
However, the TCGA pan-cancer analysis result
revealed that the messenger RNA level of
eIF4A1 is much higher than that of eIF4E and
eIF4G. We also conducted the non-denaturing
PAGE and further verified that over 90% of
eIF4A1 is outside of eIF4F complex.
So what is the biological function of the eIF4F
complex-free eIF4A1?
To explore the biological function of
free complex free
eIF4A1, we next performed BioID
assay and identified 410
proteins interacting with eIF4A1.
GSEA pathway analysis revealed that
the top enrichment of the translation initiation pathway, which
is in line with the previous findings.
Interestingly, the pathway of metabolism of RNA ranked the
second, where PAPPYB1,
HNRPA1, and HNRPA3 were both
annihilated.PLA assay confirmed the
direct colocalization between eIF4A1 and the
messenger RNA stabilizer YB-1 in the cell cytoplasm.
Co-IP assay independently verified the robust and
RNA-independent interaction between eIF4A1 and
YB-1.
Gene-specific qPCR result demonstrated the
direct binding between either eIF4A1 or
YB-1 to the PHGDH messenger RNA, and the
knockout of either eIF4A1 or YB-1 significantly
accelerated PHGDH messenger RNA degradation.
Based on the previously talked results and our other preliminary data,
which is now shown here, we proposed that the
eIF3 complex, three,
eIF4A1, together with YB-1, are the key
components of an RNA chaperone, where they protect the
messenger RNA from degradation and keep them at the
translation-ready state. However, when the eIF4A1 is
depleted, those RNA which were protected by
eIF4A1 would go into the RNP granules, such as
stress granules or P bodies, and induce their
degradation.
Zoledronate is the first-in-class FDA-approved eIF4A1 inhibitor.
Zoledronate showed a strong anti-leukemia effect in different AML cell
lines and in the AML PDX cells with the
IC50 at nanomole level. More importantly, zoledronate
showed no impact on the survival of the normal hematopoietic
cells.
Zoledronate treatment significantly inhibited AML progression in
both the immunocompetent bone marrow transplantation mouse model
and immunodeficient engrafted mouse model.
To explore the regulators that can underpin zoledronate treatment in
AML, we next employed CRISPR screening in two
independent AML cell lines. The CRISPR screening
identified over 500 sensitizers whose knockout
could promote zoledronate treatment in AML.
Here we can see YB-1 is one of the top sensitizers.
Another interesting target is MCL1, who already has
the inhibitor in the process of the clinical trial.
In our drug combination test, compared with the control group,
the MCL1 alone showed very moderate anti-leukemia
effect, and zoledronate alone significantly
inhibit AML progression, and the combination of
zoledronate and MCL1 inhibitor showed a
robust
synergistic anti-leukemia effect.
We can get very similar conclusion when it comes to the combination of
the zoledronate and the YB-1 inhibitor.
So far, we found that eIF4A1, also called DDX2A,
is the most highly expressed translation initiation factor.
It promotes AML initiation and progression.
eIF4F complex 3, eIF4A1, functions as a
chaperone, stabilizing messenger RNA such as
PHGDH, thereby facilitating serine
biosynthesis. eIF4A1 inhibitor zoledronate
alone effectively suppresses leukemogenesis,
and zoledronate exhibits robust synergist effects
with MCL1 inhibitor and YB-1 inhibitor in
AML.
Here I would like to pay tribute to my PI, Dr. Rui Su and Dr.
Jiayu, and all our collaborators. Thank you so much.
We have time for questions. I'll start with the first
one. Great talk, Xiaoxu.
Is the inhibitor,
zoletat...
What it's called? Zoledronate specific for tumor cells, or what
are effects or toxicity might be for normal cells?
Okay.
So far in our blood cancer in AML, we tested
whether zoledronate could impact the survival of the normal
hematopoietic cells we got it from the City of Hope
Blood
Center. It showed no impact or very minor impact on
the survival of those cells. But for the AML cells,
we found that at the nanomole level, with very low IC50,
it can effectively kill or inhibit the AML cell growth.
It showed very strong anti-leukemia effect.
That's for the in cellular part. But for the in vivo part, we
don't do specific experiments to
evaluate its toxicity, but we keep a
close eye
to monitor the status of the mice as well as the body weight
to evaluate its toxicity. Yeah.
Okay, thanks. One question from the back.
Yeah. This is Luke Chen from Coriell.
Very nice
presentation.
I study NF2, and I know
eIF4A1, in particular its inhibitor, would
inhibit NF2 expression. And NF2
regulates serine metabolism through transcriptional
regulation of all these genes on your list,
PHGDH or a couple of critical genes.
So do you have any comment how
the efficacy you've seen is dependent on potentially
NF2?
Thank you so much for your question.
So far, we have already explored the function of
EAF4A1 on the general serine pathway.
We have two independent methods, which is metabolic
profiling, and also we do a lot of experiments focusing
on how EAF4A1
regulates the expression of PGDH.
I think it relates to our hypothesis
about the chaperone part. We link this
part to--
We want to explain how the EAF4A1 contributes to
the chemoresistance of AML. And for your part,
thank you for your question, but I don't really do many
experiments to explain this part. Thank you.
Yeah. I would say if you overexpress NF2
while you are treating the cells with
zilactimib,
I would say you will be able to figure out whether
NF2 contributes to
these downstream effects.
Yes. Thank you for your suggestion.
We don't really do experiments for this part.
And for the rescue assay, we do a lot of
mutant rescue assay to see which domain or which
helix activity or binding activity contributes to the
regulation of EAF4A1 in AML. Thank you so much.
All right. Thank you, Xiaoxiu, for a great talk.
We'll move on to next speaker.
So I want to welcome our speaker from UC San
Diego, Emanuela
Ghia? Ghia?
Ghia.
On targeting cancer stem
cells to overcome therapy resistance in
triple-negative breast cancer.
Thank you.
Emanuela. Thank you.
Thank you. Thank you very much.
I'm very excited to be here, and I want to thank the committee for selecting
my abstract.
And I'm excited to talk about our work on anti-Rho two
therapies in triple-negative breast cancer.
I have no disclosure.
As a majority of the audience know, triple-negative breast cancer represents 15%
to 20% of all breast cancer and lacks
expression of ER, PR, and Rho2.
Higher recurrence rate and worse prognosis are observed
in triple-negative breast cancer versus other breast cancer
subtypes. And the key challenges are
cancer persistence, therapy resistance, and metastatic trajectory.
Several studies support cancer stem cell model
or cancer plasticity
as
playing a key role in conventional cancer therapy resistance,
tumor relapse, and metastasis.
Therefore, novel therapeutic targets are urgently needed.
To this end, we focus our work on Rho1 and Rho2,
which are oncoembryonic proteins, are expressed during embryogenesis
and are absent in all normal adult tissue.
They are aberrantly re-expressed in multiple cancer
mark stem-like cells, mediate stemness, EMT, and
metastasis, and upon binding with ligands like WNT5A,
activate pro-survival signaling pathways.
Our recent work evaluated the Rho1 and Rho2 gene
expression pre-treatment in
almost 1,000 patients enrolled in
I-SPY2 clinical trial. These patients had high
risk early breast cancer. And as you can see
in this graph,
we observe the gene expression of Rho1 and Rho2.
High level of gene expression of Rho1 and Rho2 in almost over
70% of the hormone receptor-negative
breast cancer.
We focus our attention on the
Rho2 and Rho1 surface expression on the
triple-negative breast cancer using CITE-seq,
which is a
barcoding antibody staining technique followed
by single cell transcriptome. And with this
multi-omics technique, we were able to
identify the proportion of cells
expressing both Rho1 and Rho2 in the
triple-negative breast cancer original biopsy,
and the respective
PDX, patient-derived xenograft model,
early passage. As you can see here, there are two different
example.
In addition, with the single cell transcriptome data, we were
able to
perform gene set enrichment analysis, and we observed that
majority of the
signature that were enriched in the Rho2 positive cells
in the original biopsy relative to the Rho2 negative cells,
were also enriched in the PDX. So
the PDX model were able to
recapitulate the
Rho2 expression and the Rho2
signaling in the original biopsy.
The
single cell transcriptome data also allowed us to
identify where the gene signature were
coming from. And basically, in this-- Sorry.
In thisIt's not showing here, unfortunately.
The
original PDX has the same
amount of Rho2 positive, and
that
has the PDX originated from a limiting dilution
experiment. So in the limiting dilution experiment, we were
able to sort Rho2 positive
cells
and
inject 5,000 or 1,000 cells, Rho2 positive or
Rho2 negative. And we observed that the
Rho2 positive were the only one
that were able to generate tumors, while the Rho2
negative didn't generate any tumors.
And the tumors generated by the
Rho2 positive cells
also include the Rho2 negative. And also the stemness
signature in the Rho2 positive cells
was observed.
The targeting the Rho2 positive
triple negative breast cancer with an anti-Rho2
monoclonal antibody revealed that
we were able to inhibit
the stemness
signature, as well as other
signaling pathways like NF-kappa B, as you can see by the
reduction of p62 level and also the
NF-kappa B activation, as you can see by the reduction of the
phospho-p65 and NRF2
targets, as
you can see by NQO1
reduction
following monoclonal antibody against
Rho2 treatment.
And NQO1
is a key regulator of antioxidant
response. And so we were interested to
see the effect of APR-246, which is an
anticancer drug that was developed to reactivate a
mutant p53 protein
by restoring its wild type conformation and thereby
disrupting its constriction to NRF2,
and therefore
allowing to increase
reactive oxygen species. And also
APR-246 depletes glutathione, inhibits redox
regulating enzyme like thiredoxin reductase.
So we perform in vitro and in vivo experiment,
treating with anti-Rho2 antibody or control
IgG followed by APR-246 in vitro.
And both experiment, you can see that the
targeting Rho2 with the monoclonal antibody makes the
cells more sensitive to APR-246, as you can see from
the
decrease of the IC50.
So in summary, I
hope I convince that Rho2 is expressed on surface of triple
negative breast cancer. Triple negative breast cancer specimen that
generate PDX have tumor cells expressing Rho2 with
the stem-like cell property, and that
the targeting of Rho2 with the monoclonal antibody
can suppress the stemness signature, inhibits NRF2 signaling,
and can increase the sensitivity to APR-246 in triple
negative breast cancer. Anti-Rho2 antibody therapy,
combined with the redox modulating agents like
APR-246, can effectively target disease persistence
and therapy resistance, and so therefore supporting future
clinical trial with the combination,
one Rho2 antibody with redox modulating agents.
I would like to thank Dr. Kipps, Dr. Shaski, and Dr.
Parker for the valuable insight and
stimulating discussion,
my colleagues, and the funding sources that
support this work. Thank you for your attention.
I'm happy to take any question.
Hey, great talk.
Sorry for the slide.
Is the antibody, it's anti-human or anti-mouse?
It's anti-human.
Oh, cool.
Yeah.
And is the activator of the p53 in clinical
trials already?
Yes. There are
clinical trials for solid tumor as well.
Yes, it is in clinical trial. Yeah.
Okay, great. Amal?
Phase one, mostly.
Very nice talk. I was just wondering, the antibody, how does it
affect the kinase activity
in cells, and whether it's competing with
its ligand in the extracellular matrix?
So the Rho1 and Rho2 are both orphan receptor,
so the
kinase activity
is
still under a lot of studies.
We are still doing
several experiment to understand that, but what we see
is that the antibody definitely inhibit the signaling
downstream of
both receptor.
Sorry, just a follow-up. So what is the antibody doing
if the receptor is
inactive, so
attaching an-
There is a residual kinase activity.
Yes.So
the antibody can inhibit the downstream signaling.
All right. Thank you
Emanuela. Great talk.
Let's move to our last but not the least
talk of the session from Dr. Brian
Cunningham at University of
Vermont Cancer Center. His talk is The
Deletion of Peroxiredoxin 3 Impairs Mitochondrial
Bioenergetics and Tumor Growth in Mesothelioma.
And all yours.
Thank you. Thank you very much. Thank you to the organizers and the chairs
for this opportunity
to discuss our program on peroxiredoxin 3 and
mesothelioma,
as well as our
efforts to target this clinically in mesothelioma.
So pleural mesothelioma is a tumor that arises from
the occupational exposure to asbestos and primarily
targets the lining of the pleural cavity, the mesothelial cell lining of
the cavity. It's a
slow-growing, long-latency tumor that takes about 20 to 40
years to develop after a possible exposure.
It has limited therapeutic options.
Just a few years ago, an immunotherapy doublet was approved for the treatment of
mesothelioma,
and it had some success, but nothing groundbreaking.
And the five-year survival rate is pretty low, 10% to 15%.
And so after this 20- to 40-year latency period, the aggressiveness of the tumor
leaves little options for patients.
Mesothelioma can be characterized as a redox-driven tumor, as a number of other
solid tumors can as well. And the characterization is that
reactive oxygen species, which are important for all cells, normal
and in disease states, can drive signaling pathways that
support the tumorigenic state. So tumor cells try to
survive in this sort of Goldilocks state, where under high levels of reactive
oxygen species, they overexpress antioxidant enzyme
pathways to protect them from the cytotoxic properties of reactive oxygen species.
So mesothelioma cells have increased levels of mitochondrial reactive oxygen
species primarily. We've shown that the key antioxidant enzymes
in the mitochondria are overexpressed in mesothelioma cells and tumor tissue.
And not only is the protein levels of these antioxidants increased, but the
activity of these antioxidants is also increased, really highlighting
the importance of balancing redox status in mesothelioma
tumors for their survival.
We focused on an enzyme called peroxiredoxin 3, which is
exclusively expressed in the mitochondrial matrix.
And peroxiredoxin 3 has a very interesting biochemical
reaction where in the presence of hydrogen
peroxide in the mitochondrial matrix, two critical cysteine
residues are involved in a redox reaction leading to a
disulfide bond that can be
regenerated by the thioredoxin system in the mitochondria.
So this enzyme's constantly cycling in the matrix to protect cells from peroxide,
and it's the most active and abundant antioxidant in the mitochondria.
Importantly, PRRX3 has been shown to protect tumor cells from oxidative stress,
and data from the Broad Institute and the PRISM screening has shown that deletion
of PRRX3 is lethal in most tumor cells, as shown in this schematic
here. Importantly, though, you can genetically delete PRRX3 from all tissues,
and these animals have no significant phenotype, highlighting its possibility as
a unique and actionable therapeutic target in oncology.
To characterize the importance of PRRX3 in mesothelioma, we generated
CRISPR-deleted human mesothelioma tumor cell lines
of biphasic histology. Here we've shown that we can effectively
delete the PRRX3 enzyme, and
the byproducts of this is a significant reduction in cell proliferation
as well as the ability of these tumor cells to form colonies in a
colony formation assay.
Additionally, their ability to grow in Matrigel is significantly disrupted.
And when we take these tumors and we inject them into the peritoneal cavity of SCID
mice, they fail to form tumors, as shown in this graph in the
histology of the tissue taken from the animals, really underlying the importance
of PRRX3 in mesothelioma tumor cell growth.
In addition, we did some functional characteristics of these cells when we
deleted PRRX3, it being the most primary and important antioxidant in the
mitochondria. We measured levels of hydrogen peroxide in the
mitochondrial matrix using a genetically encoded hydrogen peroxide sensor
called Hyper7. And as you can see both in the images and the
quantification, the deletion of PRRX3 significantly increases the
levels of hydrogen peroxide in the mitochondria of these cells.
In addition,
looking at readouts of both mitochondrial bioenergetics, looking at oxygen
consumption rates, we see a significant reduction in
all aspects of mitochondrial bioenergetics when we delete PRRX3,
as well as the reduction in extracellular acidification rate, which can be
an indirect readout of glycolysis.
So deletion of PRRX3 causes what seems to be a global metabolic defect in these
tumor cells.
To confirm this, we generated cell lines where we re-expressed a FLAG-tag
version of the protein back into the knockout cell line, as
shown here. This significantly rescued
hydrogen peroxide levels in the mitochondrial matrix of the PRRX3
knockdown cells by reducing Hyper7 expression, completely
restored mitochondrial bioenergetics, and completely restored
extracellular acidification rates, highlighting the critical role of PRRX3
in cellular metabolism.
In addition, the re-expression of PRRX3 back into these cell
lines led to a partial rescue of colony formation in a colony
formation
assay.We've conducted
RNA sequencing on these cells, comparing our wild-type cell lines to our
PRRX3 knockout cells. You can see PRRX3 being one of the number one knocked down
or reduced expressed genes. And a number of the pathways
seem to be very important in both metabolism and reactive oxygen species,
as well as cell proliferation and growth.
In addition, when we rescue PRRX3 expression through the expression of the
endogenous flag-tagged protein, we see a number of very interesting pathways,
including oxidative phosphorylation and glycolysis and hypoxia being
rescued upon the reintroduction of PRRX3.
So this is very early in hypothesis-generating data that is allowing us to look at
the role of this mitochondrial matrix enzyme in control of a number
of different gene expression patterns.
So years ago, we first identified a mechanism of
action of this large and quite ugly-looking compound, thiostrepton,
as being a covalent inhibitor of the peroxiredoxin III enzyme.
And what we've discovered is that in the catalytic cycle of
peroxiredoxin III, upon disulfide formation at one
catalytic active site, this now exposes a secondary active
site that allows for thiostrepton to form a covalent linkage
across two critical active site cysteine residues.
This is an irreversible modification.
It can be detected on a protein western blot,
as a shift in molecular weight that cannot be reduced with conventional
or pretty much any reducing agent thrown at it.
We've shown that this induces significant oxidative stress in tumor cells, leading
to tumor cell death. And we've shown that the cysteine residues, both the
resolving and peroxidatic cysteine of peroxiredoxin III to be
critical for this dimerization to occur.
Whereas if we mutate a non-catalytic cysteine to a serine in PRRX3, we still get
the cross-linking. So we've characterized the active site cross-linking and
mechanism of this compound.
Thiostrepton has also been investigated by the Broad Institute in the PRISM screen
and shown to have quite abundant activity in a number of
different tumor cell lines, as shown here on the
left. We've shown activity in mesothelioma cell
models,
and a therapeutic window between normal and tumor cells.
And we've also shown in a number of mouse models, both
immunosuppressed and immunocompetent mouse models, the ability
for thiostrepton to induce anti-tumor activity.
This data and significant other data not presented today supported the clinical
development of thiostrepton as RS-021,
which is the clinical formulation of three mg per ml solution, and the start of the
MITOPE clinical trial, which is focused on patients who have malignant
pleural effusions rising from mesothelioma or metastatic disease.
These patients are given an intrapleural catheter to drain the
pleural effusion liquid, and then RS-021 is a local regional therapy that is
injected directly back into the pleural cavity.
And these patients can secure their IPC, and this is a
once-a-week treatment until disease progression.
Here's some data from the Phase 1 clinical trial where we showed
plasma levels of thiostrepton when injected intrapleurally are
actually relatively low, so the treatment is being contained to the pleural
cavity.
We are able to see that the protein cross-linking of the PRRX3
enzyme is occurring in pleural effusions derived from these patients, so the
mechanism of action is retained in these patients.
We had a number of drainages on the course of treatment.
Here's data from the Phase 1 showing individual patient responses, so
a spider plot showing radiological activity of the drug against
the tumors, with some patients having significant and persistent
responses.
Our progression-free survival was in line with a majority of treatments already
available to patients, and our overall survival is showing
meaningful impact for these patients.
So the MITOPE Phase 1 trial met its primary endpoint of safety and tolerability,
and our Phase 2 testing has recently completed in the past months.
This data will be presented later this year.
In an effort to understand biomarkers that could predict
response and treatment effects, we conducted explant testing
of taking surgically removed patient tumors and testing them ex
vivo for activity against the thiostrepton drug.
And using markers such as cytokeratin, cleaved PARP, and Ki-67,
we can now look at the response of these tumor tissues ex vivo and characterize
responses.
So in this waterfall plot, these are all individual patient-derived explants that
are either responding or not responding to the treatment.
And with this, we can conduct RNA sequencing and not showing all the data.
One of the top hits that came out of our screen was the increased
expression of SLC7A11 in non-responding patient explants.
SLC7A11 is a protein in the plasma membrane
that
supports the export of glutamate and import of
cysteine, primarily used for glutathione synthesis and protection of
cells from oxidative stress and lipid-induced cell death through
ferroptosis.
We confirm the importance of SLC7A11 in thiostrepton
treatment by using siRNA to SLC7A11, and
you can see a significant reduction in IC50
and increased sensitivity to thiostrepton when the SLC7A11
transporter is knocked down.
In addition, using a research grade
inhibitor of SLC7A11, we're able to show synergy between
thiostrepton and erastin,
further validating the importance of the SLC7A11
protein in
therapeutic response to thiostrepton.
So in conclusion, we've been working to show that PRRX3 is a validated oncology
target that supports tumor cell growth.
Thiostrepton is a covalent inhibitor of PRRX3 that has anti-tumor
activity.
RS-021, the clinical version of thiostrepton, is safe and shows
signs of efficacy in humans. Our Phase 2 testing recently completed.
And SLC7A11 seems to be an indicator of response to
thiostrepton and could possibly be used to predict patient
outcomes.If you have time tomorrow, you could come to my poster.
We've been doing a significant amount of work looking at the immunomodulatory
capacity of thiostrepton,
and have some pretty nice data showing synergism with immunotherapy.
With that, I'd like to thank the members of my lab.
Victoria Gibson, a graduate student in my lab, did a lot of this work in
combination with Aida and Terry. And our great
collaborators, both pre-clinically, translational, and clinically at the University
of Leicester in Dr. Tien Fennell's lab, and all the investigators, patients,
and families involved in the MITOPE trial, and our research funding from
philanthropic and industry sponsorship. Thank you for your time.
Thank you, Brian.
We have time for a few questions. I'll start with
one. It's exciting to see the inhibitor goes into phase
one trial and also showing efficacy from the
reports that you show a few patients do responded
better than the others. Do you have any biomarkers can help
predict their response?
Yeah. So the explant data certainly supports SLC7A11.
The problem there is that's overexpressed in a lot of resistant tumors.
We have some really interesting proteomics data from pleural effusions
taken from patients on treatment, and so we're trying to map that to
responses. The phase one was not a lot of patients, 15
patients or so. But now that we have data from the phase two, upwards of 50
patients or so, we have much more samples that we can start to align
these.
And the access to that cavity to get tissue allows us to ask some of those
questions.
Thank you. Samal?
Very nice talk. So,
your target is very well validated.
So, the inhibitor looks very
not so attractive, right?
Sure.
To say the least. So
is there a way to improve
on that? Looks like-
Yeah.
... it's worth doing, right?
Yeah. That's a great question. So yeah.
Nobody with a sane mind would put this drug into a clinical development
program, but
we did it and it's working. And it has limitations, for
sure. We recently just had a scientific reports paper published with
collaborators where we've found the limited chemical
scaffold required for PRRX3 inhibition.
And so we've built off of that scaffold to start doing structure activity
relationship to try and build second generation molecules.
And those actually reduce a lot of the off-target effects that we see with
the original molecule. So there is a strong desire and program
to generate new and improved PRRX3 inhibitors.
Okay. Thank you.
Thank you.
Hi. Jeff Perry, City of Hope. I was just curious,
do you have any concerns about inducing secondary diabetes or that kind of
thing, messing around with redox in the mitochondria?
So,
no.
Not in patients with mesothelioma,
for sure. And I don't think we've seen any of that in the patients treated.
And I guess I'd ask for a little bit more clarification of why.
I would say, too, with the local treatment, this is really
confined to the pleural space, so we can see in the future
with more systemic therapies. But,
I'd be curious just to elaborate a bit.
Yeah. Agreed on that. If it stays local, then it's probably less of a concern.
Yeah.
Systemic, I think, would be quite a concern.
I think your talk and the talk before also hitting thyroxine and-
Yeah
... because tiksnip is the protein that's really driving diabetes and oxidative
stress in it, so it's thyroxine and these
antioxidants that are stopping it, so.
Sure. Yeah. Well, interesting. I'll have to keep that in mind with our second
generation development program. Thank you for that.
Yeah. As a follow-up, what is the advantage or
why you chose the local regional delivery instead of
systemic or what are concerns that
Yeah. So really, this clinical trial and program with the
thiostrepton drug really served as a proof of principle clinical trial.
And thiostrepton, unfortunately, is very insoluble, very
challenging to formulate, as you can probably imagine from the chemical
structure. But we actually succeeded in generating a
formulation
that retained activity of the drug, had a favorable safety
profile in IND studies. And
therefore, with our collaborators in the UK,
they're very interested in local therapies to reduce toxicity and
get increased drug abundance in the cavity, and so they were very
supportive of this mechanism to treat locally.
So the hope is, though, in the future, with second generation drugs, to be able to
treat systemically.
So that's the goal, yeah.
Yeah. Have you seen the PRRX3 upregulated in other tumor types?
Yeah. So we do see PRRX3 upregulated in other tumor types.
PRRX3 is already expressed at extremely high levels.
It's expressed at 20 micromolar in the mitochondria of cells.
So there's a lot of it there.
Actually, the better readout is we can measure its activity, and we do see a
significant increase in its activity and cycling in tumor cells.
So it seems to be a pretty interesting and novel target that we could go
after.
Yeah.
All right. Thank you, Ryan, and thank all the short
talk presenters. And now we can open for a little
bit AI-focused discussions, and I know many of you have
been doing AI research. We want to get your
comments, suggestions how can we accelerate
in our research and move the field forward
using AI technologies.
John, you want to start any kind of suggestions?
I know your lab has been doing a lot of machine learning.
Well, it seems to me that this is really a pivotal
time in cancer biology and therapy
becauseWe have so many better
methods in molecular, structural,
cellular biology. At the same time,
the AI allows us to take these large
mind-boggling data sets and just drill them
down to focus issues that can become
therapeutically targeted. And
so we want to get people's feedback on what would
really be useful. We heard this morning about these
large, more general
AI packages and approaches, but
is there really a role then
for a specific AI targeted toward
antibodies or drug discovery, or do we want
general AI that can read all the
papers on tumors and come up with
protocols? Or what would be most useful to you
guys in terms of really combating
resistance and targeting tumors, I mean,
cancer in general? I'd like to get
feedback from people. I could
maybe stimulate people to talk about RNA or
other targets and how AI would
speak to that. Or
what's useful for you to talk about?
I know you all
have a busy schedule at this conference, but I think we're all
here with an idea to think about resistance
and AI and the
extremely powerful technologies we have to
generate data.
Yeah, I think that one of the things we don't really understand is how to
design drugs or interventions that
is more difficult for the tumor to evolve resistance to.
Like what features should we be designing in to delay
resistance? And I'm hopeful that AI might be able to help
discover some design principles or types of things that would
slow down resistance.
A very salient point about thinking about
resistance ahead of time so that it's in the
design rather than something that we have to deal with
when it happens.
Yeah, I think this is a really critical question to the
field. How do we really predict acquired
resistance ahead of time? It's like a race between
your approach against the tumor's
evolution. I think the
integration or incorporation of AI technologies, hopefully, we
can really predict how cells are going to move next
step, so you actually know. It's like chess.
Can you really predict how many moves they have?
And then can you really predict ahead of the moves,
what we can do to actually prevent the development
of acquired resistance?
Yeah, so I think one question that nobody tackled too much.
We are designing small molecules for proteins because everybody knows small
molecules are targeting proteins, but they can target RNAs.
And this is an absolute open field with about one million
transcripts that we are never trying to target through small
molecules. So I think there are a lot of boundaries
that we have to break in order to get over
resistance and to really treat any and each
of the patients. So I would say to me at least, and hear John knows and Zaman
the same, the next frontier, it's small
molecules targeting the transcriptome, not the
proteome.
Yeah, I think this is a big
area that's underutilized. We've heard talks at
this conference about
splicing factors, binding damage response proteins, and
inducing
different repair or DNA damage response defects that make
you sensitive or resistant to PARP inhibitor or
other poly theta inhibitors. And I
think the RNA is now accessible for
structural biology by cryo-EM and also X-ray
scattering. Given that you can computationally
model them to some extent, and then if you have
experimental data, I think AI will bootstrap to
atomic structures. So this is probably important to think about
maybe both targeting the RNA and the
protein so you can control things at two
levels.
Yeah.
I think maybe the critical steps are how can you
identify the best targets for the RNA
field or protein field? Because the resources,
we have to prioritize. So hopefully the virtual screens
will help us accelerate to come to the best
targets or prioritize the targets, because there's just so
many global targets that you may be able to
identify. But what is the strategy for us to go after the
best ones so we can save time and accelerate?
And you guys can turn your ideas about these points
into action if you want. I know AACR is
looking for
session topics and ideas for their next
meeting, and so you can suggest what you feel the gap
is and try and be involved in filling it,
I think
Maybe I want to ask question, how many of you feel lost from the AI
sessions, like the plenary sessions?
And then what can we really do in our daily research?
You can talk about foundation models or agentic AI.
What can we really do in our daily research so we hope
we can actually tailor the AI models, the
AI technologies to our daily research can really
accelerate? Yeah, maybe that's the topic so that we can
suggest it to not only just the high level
of AI, but we really want to come to our
specific kind of AI accelerated
research.
Brian.
I just want to make one comment because
I'm very overwhelmed by it all. Right? I'm a cell biologist by training.
I can barely open an Excel file.
But we're obviously very keen on
exploring this PRX three target or pick your favorite target,
right? And we're keen. We know one mechanism by which we can
interact with it through this kind of crazy covalent interaction.
What I've been fascinated with, how do we
look for other aspects of the molecule to target, et cetera?
And have been in many meetings with many AI drug
discovery companies who've looked right at me in the eye and said, "This is going
to be easy." And I said, "Well, I don't think it is," because
the crystal structure, I don't think actually reflects
the dynamics of the protein, right?
And so at least very-- I think some of these targets like that
have lots of conformational changes and
I know this because we have a collaborator who just generated a second crystal
structure that's completely different than what's published and what
AlphaFold can do. And my major concern is,
our first speaker talked about this, right? Crap in, crap out.
If you start with a really bad structure, you start with something really undefined
or a library that's not completely validated,
it could send us down the wrong track for a very, very, very long time.
I'm excited about the idea, though, of integrating cell data, patient
data, atomic resolution data,
and just really filling up that basket with so many different data points that
allow us to make informed decisions going forward.
I think it's exciting, but it's very overwhelming.
I mean, to me, your talk was really
fun and interesting because
you did something that's informative, yet it violated
basically every rule, right? I mean, it was too big to get into
cells. Obviously, it's positively uptaken.
You're making a covalent inhibitor, violates all the
rule of five and everything, right?
But I think one thing about AI that we
should be open to is if you think about
DeepMind and what they did is they
made
Go game programs that would compete against each other.
And then when the expert from Korea
or maybe it was China was playing it,
the machine, the AI, made a move
that had never been-- Totally unexpected.
Like the guy walked out of the room and walked in the garden, came back, and he
lost. And so AI can come up with
these things that are kind of like your project, where you
violate all the rules, but yet you learn something and
you have something that may benefit patients.
So I think-
I think it's an excellent example
... the ability to coordinate large amounts of data
may give us unexpected
avenues to combat resistance.
I think it's an excellent example because we've subscribed to these rules, which
have helped. They've worked, right?
But-
But they limit us.
They limit us. That's a great example.
The AI doesn't have any limits. It'll find
something completely weird. But I mean, you wouldn't expect it for
Go, because, I mean, it's the game that's been played a thousand
years by all these expert people who are
supposed to be more intelligent than programs.
But yet this program made
a completely unexpected move that baffled the world's
expert, right? And that's showing us what the
potential is. And in cancer, where there's just
enormous amounts of data that we can't, I can't
wrap my mind around, but the machine's
learning can, right? And so this is an
opportunity we have to learn to harness in our
own research, I guess.
But I agree with Brian. It is a great kind of
point to make. How do we train? And then you have
to train the AI properly, otherwise it may give you a
wrong answer. Or how can we validate after
the AI provides you some clues? That's important.
For Go game, it's probably easy to validate.
But for cancer research is expensive and
difficult to validate it. You don't want to get a wrong
direction until you've gotten too far.
But I think every step, kind of appropriate
validation is important.
So I just want to add a couple of things.
So a lot of the data and target that
we currently go after for cancer based on
knockout, knockdown.
And one of the problem with knockout and knockdown, you take the protein
out of the system, something else will take over.
But an inhibitor, I mean, from my work, what I see is
like a guess
where it needs to go, but then it's trapped.
So not only it's inhibiting the function, it's actually inhibiting function of
something else that may take over that function.
So I think with the AI, I think we have the opportunity,
maybe not
a drug, but you could have a tool to
sort of study this effect rather than sort of having
a knockout and knockdown, which I think,
it works, but oftentimes it doesn't
translate in cancer.
Yeah, I totally think that. I'm really excited
you brought up that point because
I think it hasn't been brought up. And if you think of
these things as networks and things
that rebalance, and then you
put in an inactive or a misactive thing in the network,
it really can trap.
So if you have to go from signaling network to an effector or
repair or whatever network, and you stop at the
signaling level, you trapped it, right?
And it's a change in thinking from the
chemistry where you have a linear pathway, and if you take something
out of a pathway, oh, you block that pathway.
But in a network, there are many paths, right?
And it's completely different. The reality is that
there aren't that many linear pathways.
Instead, you have these dynamic complexes that change
over time. So I think your point is really pertinent.
I'm sorry, go ahead.
I think your point about the Go is actually an interesting
counterexample, because
by playing itself is able to explore a lot of data space that hadn't been explored
by humans. Whereas I think we have to be very careful about the data that we're
training the models on. For instance, there's probably a ton more data
that's consistent with the rule of five and very little data of people who have
broken that rule.
Correct.
So we might benefit by thinking about how to
generate more general data sets to train our models than what
we've already explored, essentially.
Yeah, that's a great point.
Yeah. Thank you.
I think we should let people go.
Yeah.
But if you have good ideas for sessions, send them to ACR
and make your own session-
Yeah
... and help us solve these problems. So thank you all for being here.
Yeah. All right, that's great.
Yeah.
I thought it was great.
Yeah, it's great. I just want to say thank you for moderating the session.
Great work.
Yeah. Very exciting. Yeah.
Yeah.
And congratulations for-
Good for you
... yeah, being chosen as a PhD student.
Oh. Thank you. Yeah. It's great for your career. Yeah.
Hey, Prem. How you doing?
Good to see you, dude.
Hi. Good. How are you doing? We can invite these short talk
speakers for a photo if you're still here.
One more.
We can take a...
Are we-
You want to take a photo
with
the-- Yeah.
We're doing a photo?
Yeah. We can do a photo with the presenters if you still stay.
Awesome.
Nice. Yeah.
Yeah.
Thank you so much.
She said she's going to follow up.
Yeah.
Let's do a photo.
Where do we do?
Let's do it here.
So that's with the background?
Okay,
come here.
Sorry, the computer guy went to the restroom.
Oh, okay.
SIGGRAPH.
Are you the speaker? Oh, no. Okay.
Very short meeting.
I guess.
Is it
this
one?
Yeah. Oh, no, it's not this one.
231.
I'm gonna take
a one.
What's your name? Morgan Reed.
What name?
It's Jackie. I
like you.
Have we done great?
Yes. You can change.
We have people that are
connected.
Okay.
Where are
you
from?
Yeah. Thank
you.
You're welcome. We're all from different cities.
Great. Yeah. Great talks and very exciting work.
Yeah.
We too can take one. Actually, do you mind?
I'll take another one with Jennifer.
Oh, okay. Sure. Oh, okay.
Patient
data.
Okay.
Cell data.
Yeah.
How are you doing? Is everything okay?
Yeah, that's fine. Yeah. Okay, tomorrow maybe.
Oh, tomorrow. Oh, sorry for that.
No problem.
Oh, sorry. Yeah.
Okay. Yeah. Okay,
exciting.
Okay. Thank you.